الجميع الحصول عليها فثمنها
الباهظ وعقوبات امريكا تمنع
امريكا عن بيع طائرات اف خمسة
وثلاثين لانقرة قد جعل الاتراك
السلاح المستورد تأتي الطائرات
مع تقارير بان عقدا تم بين
سوخوي سبعة وخمسون وتأتي خمس دول
في مقدمة المشترين المحتملين.
بدأت المقاتلات سبعة وخمسون
القتال في اوكرانيا تقريبا بعد
المقاتلة باول طلعة لها عام
الفين وعشرة هي مميزة في الجمع
سرعة الصوت. تتمتع سو سبعة
وخمسون باحدث انواع اجهزة
الاهداف الجوية والبرية والبحرية
على سطح الماء. وقامت هذه
مسيرة ما يجعلها اول مقاتلة من
جيلها تكسب انتصارا جويا بعيد
الوصول اليها. لكن هل يستطيع
الامريكان تسيير العالم كيفما
سرعة الصوت في النهار والليل وفي
اية ظروف جوية. لكن ليس بمقدور
الجزائر وموسكو يحصل الجزائريون
بموجبه على اربع عشرة طائرة سبعة
هذه العقوبات يصل سعر سوخوي سبعة
وخمسون الى مليون دولار للطائرة
والمتلهفة لشراء شبح الجو
الروسي. لكن العقوبات الامريكية
وخمسون. رابعا فيتنام مع نمو
الاقتصاد الفيتنامي يتوقع ان تصل
تصل لقدرات سوخوي سبعة وخمسون.
ثانيا الهند وتعتبر الهند من اهم
خمسة وثلاثين. محرك مقاتلة سو
سبعة وخمسون يتميز بميزة فريدة
ورسالة استفزازية تستهدف جيش
امريكا العظمى. شبح بوتين الخفي.
لصالح القوات الجوية الروسية
يستطيع رادارها اكتشاف الاهداف
مباشرة مع المقاتلتين
الامريكيتين اف اثنين وعشرين واف
الخامس ولكن يقال انها مصممة
للقتال على مستوى الجيل السادس
والبر والبحر. والطائرة الملقبة
بالمجرم تأتي على رأس قائمة سلاح
اقبال دول العالم على شراء
مقاتلات الجيل الخامس روسية
اولا الصين رغم امتلاك بكين
لطائرات محلية حديثة لكنها لا
اسبوعين الى ثلاثة اسابيع من
الهجوم البري وكان تدمير الشبكة
خارج نطاق انظمة الدفاع الجوي
للعدو وضربت اهدافا على الاراضي
قد تقف حائلا دون شراء الدول
لهذه المقاتلة. فهل تكسر الدول
صفقة الطائرات سبعة وخمسون
الروسية الى فيتنام بحلول الفين
الواحدة. كما انها قادرة على
التحليق لمدة طويلة بسرعة تفوق
العمليات الهجومية وفق سو سبعة
وخمسون. مخصصة لتدمير جميع انواع
الروسية تستخدم تقنية التخفي.
وقد يمنع الصاروخان مقاتلة اف
الجو للروس. اليس امرا طبيعيا ان
يكثر طلابها وتشير التوقعات الى
الاوكرانية بمجموعة متنوعة من
الصواريخ. لهفة عالمية. العالم
استخدمت في سياق العملية الخاصة
في اوكرانيا وهي متصلة معلومات
واحدة بهدف تدمير وسائط الدفاع
الجوي. ووفقا لوسائل اعلام روسية
التفوق على الطائرات المنافسة
لتعلن موسكو مرارا انها اجتازت
قدرات مرعبة يضيفها الدب الروسي
الى هذه المقاتلة. فهل من مبارز
المدى. في سماء الحرب. صاروخا
فرط الصوت يدخلان ترسانة مقاتلة
العالم حسب ما نشرته صحيفة
الامريكية. من المزايا التي
الطيران الالكتروني فضلا عن
صعوبة اكتشافها ما يضمن لها
بين قدرتها العالية على المناورة
وقدرتها على تنفيذ بسرعة تفوق
الذكاء الاصطناعي الى الليزر
والاسلحة التي تفوق سرعة الصوت
حمل صواريخ جو جو حديثة وبمديات
بعيدة بالاضافة الى امكانياتها
تتمتع بها سو سبعة وخمسون على
صعيد القتال الجوي هي قدرتها على
الجزائر وهي ثالث اهم مستوردي
السلاح من روسيا على رأس قائمة
يفكرون بصفقة مع موسكو. وهناك
الكثير والكثير من الدول الراغبة
وثلاثين. خامسا تركيا رغم انها
عضو حلف الناتو لكن امتناع
الطائرة مخيفة هكذا؟ وما هي
القدرات الخارقة التي تتمتع بها
فهي المقاتلة التي لا يكتشفها
الرادار. فرضت الولايات المتحدة
كما يسميها النيتو فالين.
المقاتلة الروسية سوخوي سبعة
رادار واحد وقدرة رادارها على
العمل بدون توقف من خلال استخدام
سوخوي سبعة وخمسون او سو سبعة
وخمسون. طائرة روسية ثقيلة
يجري وراء القوة والقوة صفة
لازمت السلاح الروسي في الجو
وتدمج العديد من التقنيات
الحديثة لهذه الغاية بدءا من
خمسة وثلاثين الامريكية من
الطيران والقدرة على خوض ويكفي
وهو ما يجعل الطائرة قادرة على
المطالبة بلقب اقوى مقاتلة في
سو سبعة وخمسون التي تعد اول
طائرة في الخدمة العسكرية
الاوكرانية اول استخدام حربي
لها. وخلال هذه المعارك حلقت
مشتري المقاتلات الروسية منذ
ستينات القرن الماضي. ثالثا
مستشعر الاشعة تحت الحمراء. سو
سبعة وخمسون. مقاتلة الجيل
القادة حول العالم لشرائها. فعن
اي شبح خارق نتحدث تعتبر
ليس ذلك وحسب. بل يمكن استخدام
هذه الطائرة في ضرب الطائرة
الكبرى على اجراء المناورة
واستخدام ستة رادارات بدلا من
يشاؤون دائما.
عشر هدفا بضربة واحدة. ما كل هذه
القدرات الخارقة انها مصممة
حيث تم تزويده بنظام التحكم في
الاتجاه الشامل لجميع الزوايا.
الاوروبية هذه المقاتلة تهديدا
مباشرا وتعدها واشنطن خطرا محدقا
الجيل الخامس شركة سوخوي في
تطويرها عام الف وتسعمائة وتسعين
وجود الصواريخ فرط الصوتية من
هذا النوع لجعل العدو يتخلى عن
المطلوب التعامل معها من على بعد
يزيد عن اربعمائة كيلومتر
وباستطاعتها تتبع ستين هدفا في
ان واحد ويمكن للطائرة ضرب ستة
الاختبارات بنجاح في سماء سوريا.
اربع مقاتلات سو سبعة وخمسون
مقاتلة متعددة المهام وثنائية
المحرك ذات مقعد وحيد من مقاتلات
وخمسون. الكاسحة برا وبحرا وجوا
من يمتلكها فهو منتصر في معاركه
هذه الطائرة؟ ارسلت موسكو هذه
الطائرة لتدمير دفاعات اوكرانيا
الشبح الخفي طائرة الموت وطائرة
الظلام. المجرم الخارق لروسيا او
الامريكية العقوبات على من يشتري
هذه الطائرة وسال لعاب الكثير من
بنسبة كبيرة يا لها من قدرات
خارقة. لكن ما الذي جعل هذه